Let's see.
Uh,
I'm,
you're a handout.
I,
I have Yates on the subject of magic.
This,
this goes back in time,
uh,
from the,
text we were discussing last time in the teens and twenties to 1901.
And I wanted to a introduce it to you as some of Yeats is reflections on the
general question of,
uh,
the occult and of,
the,
um,
uh,
symbolic,
in his poetry,
um,
kind of preparation in his thinking for some of the poems we discussed last
time,
such as the second coming.
Uh,
he says,
I believe in the practice and philosophy of what we have agreed to call magic,
uh,
and what I must call the evocation of spirits,
though I do not know what they are.
That's important.
I think in,
you remember Yates in the second coming,
uh,
you know,
there's a beast that's coming because know what it is.
Uh,
and,
and here he's saying something similar and he says,
uh,
also speaks of his belief in the power of creating magical illusions in the
visions of truth,
in the depths of the mind when the eyes are closed.
Uh,
and I believe in three doctrines which he will conveniently put forward for us.
One,
uh,
that the borders of our mind and he has that and the singular there are ever
shifting and that many minds can flow into one another as it were.
That's probably an important,
uh,
qualification,
and create or reveal a single mind,
a single energy in effect at work in our,
our common imaginations that the borders of our minds are shifting.
Uh,
and that our memories are part of one great memory when he calls the memory of
nature herself.
And this is the most important thing that this great mind and great memory,
this kind of unitary repitoire of,
of,
uh,
spirits and memories can be evoked by symbols.
Uh,
is this something poetry can activate and,
and,
uh,
draw upon,
that Spiritus Mundi that,
that a Yates refers to in the second coming?
Well,
this is Yates talking about that idea here.
Uh,
it is something as he stresses that can be evoked by symbols,
by poetic symbols in this he intends to do in his,
in his poetry.
Uh,
in fact,
Yates sees,
uh,
um,
his poems as a kind of summoning of spirits or evocation of spirits as he refers
to it.
Uh,
last time I talked just briefly about Yates is interest in automatic writing,
a practice that he engaged in with his wife.
Uh,
well,
his poems,
uh,
themselves have a cult dimension,
of,
uh,
evoking,
um,
this great mind,
uh,
and the spirits contained there in through symbols.
He also stresses that the borders of our minds and of individual identity are
ever shifting and unstable.
Uh,
and that,
um,
well behind all of these ideas I think is,
is a sense of,
um,
uh,
the poet as a figure who channels in his life as well as in his writing,
channels,
spirits and presences,
uh,
and voices,
importantly.
Uh,
and this is related to two.
Yates is idea that the poet,
and this is something he wrote about in the pros I asked you to read for today,
that the poet is more type than man.
Uh,
on eight 84,
uh,
late in his life,
writing a kind of a summary comment on his work.
For the,
uh,
collected edition being produced by the publisher Scribner's.
Uh,
he,
he writes a certain important summary propositions about his work,
but about poetry in general.
And he says on eight 84,
a poet writes,
always have his personal life in his finest work out of its tragedies,
whatever it may be,
remorse,
loss,
love are mere loneliness.
He never speaks directly as to someone at the breakfast table.
There is always a phantasmagoria.
Dante and Milton had mythologies,
Shakespeare,
the characters of English,
history of traditional romance and so on.
Uh,
he says,
um,
uh,
the,
the writer is more type than man,
more passion than type P is lear,
Romeo,
Oedipus,
Tyree,
CEUs.
He has stepped out of a play.
And even the woman,
he loves his Rosalind Cleopatra,
never the dark lady.
Uh,
well,
uh,
he is part of his own phantasmagoria and we adore him because nature has grown
intelligible.
And by doing so,
uh,
we,
we apprehend a part of our creative power,
uh,
in the poet and in his work,
nature grows intelligible.
This is an important idea for a Yates.
Uh,
and it suggests that though life is rooted,
or excuse me,
that work is rooted in life for a Yates.
It's always a,
a life transformed,
uh,
fed through this phantasmagoria that he's,
he's discussing,
uh,
which is important because,
at once,
Yates is insisting on,
on,
uh,
on the personal nature of,
his poetry and have the experience it offers.
And yet he's also interestingly,
uh,
um,
curiously impersonal,
a figure,
a impersonal poet.
On eight 87,
he says towards the,
uh,
top of the,
page,
um,
uh,
he says,
um,
talk to me of originality and I will turn on you with rage.
I am a crowd.
I'm a lonely man.
I am nothing ancient.
Salt is best packing.
Uh,
uh,
the,
the heroes of Shakespeare conveyed to us through their looks or through their
metaphorical patterns of speech,
the sudden enlargement of their vision,
their ecstasy at the approach of death,
uh,
and,
and so on.
And this is the kind of,
um,
uh,
impersonal channeling of,
emotion that,
um,
uh,
Yates himself,
a kind of actor in his poetry wishes to convey,
uh,
on your,
on your handout,
there's another,
a quotation from late in Yates,
his life that I wanted to emphasize.
He says,
and here's that [inaudible] word all again.
when I try to put all into a phrase,
I say,
man can embody truth,
but he cannot know it.
Man can embody truth,
I must embody it.
And the completion of my life,
the abstract is not life in everywhere draws out its contradictions.
You can refute Hagle but not the saint or the song of experience.
And it's a wonderful claim.
You can,
you can refute Hagle but not a,
the saint or the song of experience.
Um,
man can embody truth but cannot know it.
This is,
this is a important formulation.
I think of it as a kind of reply to that famous question in later.
And the Swan,
uh,
that is,
did she put on his knowledge with his power before the indifferent beak could
let her drop?
Uh,
the answer that Yates is giving here is different from saying either yes or no
to that question.
Uh,
it's more,
uh,
like saying yes and no.
I think truth is something to be embodied in Yates,
uh,
embodied rather than known,
embodied in the sense of lived,
uh,
not merely understood but experienced.
But also I think embodied because it is specifically a thing of the body and
involves an experience of the body.
Uh,
as much as we're more than the mind,
uh,
what kind of knowledge,
if any,
can be had from the shattering experiences of revolution or rape?
Uh,
those models of history that I proposed last time,
remember how,
uh,
how Yates represents history as rape in late in the Swan,
he sees it there as an experience of violence,
uh,
of sexual violence involving the intercourse of opposites of God and man,
a eternity and time,
male and female,
the will and patterning force of the one thing against the other imposed on it
by brute force.
What kind of knowledge can be had from that experience?
Uh,
late in the swan seems to say a knowledge of the body.
of the necessity of embodiment,
uh,
in,
in the late Yates,
in the poems that I'll be discussing today.
Uh,
there's no knowledge apart from the body.
and this is,
this is something to contrast with the early Yates and it's high idealism,
uh,
and it's,
um,
uh,
it's drive to,
exist in an abstract,
uh,
and,
ideal world.
The late Yates,
uh,
this is a poetry,
written,
uh,
in age,
and written about age and aging,
uh,
age scene and,
and experienced as the failure and corruption of the body to which the soul is
bound,
uh,
in,
in sailing to Byzantium,
uh,
kind of transitional poem.
Two,
two later Yates,
uh,
on,
on one 23 in your book,
um,
Yeats says an aged man is but a paltry thing,
a tattered coat upon a stick.
Unless soul clap its hands and Lao and sing and louder sing for every tatter and
its mortal dress
poet speaks of his soul there as,
um,
uh,
as,
as sick with desire and fastened to a dying animal that is the body.
And yet for all of it,
but complaints about the body,
uh,
here in this poem.
And,
and,
and in other late,
yeah,
the poet doesn't,
it doesn't reject that dying animal,
uh,
doesn't scoring it.
Uh,
instead,
Yates affirms,
it,
affirms the body,
uh,
in its corrupt state.
Uh,
he in fact sings and sings louder for it.
In this late poetry,
uh,
sings louder as he puts it for every tatter in the soul's mortal dress.
Uh,
this is the extraordinary energy of,
of Yates is late poetry a,
what he calls the word he has for the energy of this,
uh,
poetry and have this attitude towards life is joy or Gaiety,
words that recur throughout these poems.
Joy,
gaiety or sometimes madness.
Uh,
their,
their joy and gaiety are both states of mind associated with madness.
Uh,
in,
in these poems,
the body's truth felt as an experience of joy or of Gatti is arrived at through
a kind of a shattering of the body and an of the rational mind.
And it's working.
Um,
Gaddy,
uh,
for Yates seems to represent some reconstitution of,
of mind and body,
uh,
some experience of their unity,
out beyond an experience of tragedy and grief.
Uh,
this is a,
a point of view specifically associated in,
in gates is late poetry with old men and with women particularly,
but not only old women.
Uh,
he says,
uh,
on eight 86 back in that general introduction from my work,
we,
eh,
this is interesting.
He's talking here about the kind of style he wishes to,
um,
create in poetry,
which involves for him,
uh,
making the language of poetry coincide with that of passionate normal speech.
He says,
I wanted to write and this a version of Frost's ambition,
uh,
though conducted differently.
I want to write in whatever language comes most naturally when we soliloquies as
I do all day long upon the events of our own lives or in any life where we can
see ourselves for the moment.
I sometimes compare myself with myself with the old man,
old slum women.
I hear denouncing and remembering how dare you,
I heard one of them say to imaginary sooner,
and you without health their home,
if I spoke,
my thoughts allow,
they might be as angry and as wild.
Uh,
so this is a kind of model for the late Yates in,
uh,
poetry,
the,
uh,
the voice of the angry and wild slum woman.
Well,
uh,
in order to,
get at this style in action and the eight says late poems.
I want to look back a little bit,
uh,
at a,
a poem that looks back on Easter 1916.
Uh,
the palm I discussed last time as well as,
uh,
excuse me,
as well as the hates his
own earlier poetry.
And that is the palm called in memory of Eva Gore booth and cotton Markowitz.
On page one 26.
It's a kind of postscript to Easter 1916,
uh,
written in 1929 con markets was the only surviving leader of the Easter rising a
condemned to death.
But then her sentence was transmute,
uh,
trans,
what is it done?
Yeah,
thank you.
Commuted,
not transmit it.
Um,
uh,
well,
con Markowitz is in a sense of figure like later,
uh,
she is someone who has suffered the traumatic violence that in genders history
a Yates is allergy here.
Uh,
uh,
recalls her youth and that if her sister,
both friends of the younger Yates,
uh,
Eva Gore booth,
youth spent uh,
in the slag oh mansion Lyssa Dell,
uh,
where Yates visited in 1894.
Uh,
at that point the eighth was 1894.
Yates is 29 and the two women were slightly younger.
Let me read the beginning of it.
The light of evening.
Alyssa Dell,
great windows open to the south to girls in Silk Kimonos.
Both beautiful one a gazelle.
Okay.
But a raving autumn sheers blossom from the summer's wreath.
The older is condemned to death,
pardoned,
drags out lonely years conspiring among the ignorant.
Okay.
I know not what the younger dreams,
some vague utopia and she seems when withered old and skeleton gaunt an image of
such politics.
Okay.
Many a time I think to seek one or the other out in speak of that old Georgian
mansion mix pictures of the mind.
Recall that table and the talk of youth to girls in Silk Kimonos,
both beautiful one,
a gazelle
here,
female beauty 19th century manners and aristocratic culture are all held
together as if expressing each other,
uh,
and,
and associated with each other.
Uh,
Yates is nostalgic.
Vision of them is charmed,
uh,
and static interestingly static.
Uh,
see how the verb is withheld in the first sentence of the poem.
And then in the closing lines of that first strokey,
uh,
that,
well,
uh,
W W in,
in order to give us that image to girls and Silk Kimono,
both beautiful one a gazelle,
which he returns to.
Uh,
it's,
it's as if the action itself are being withheld from the charmed world,
uh,
in time slowed down or even stopped,
making a picture,
an image,
a Haiku.
Uh,
but all of this is overthrown,
changed utterly,
uh,
by the radical politics that altered Ireland during Yates is lifetime than
announced the coming of modernity.
Uh,
and that these two women themselves participated in a centrally politics,
makes them ugly to Yates.
Uh,
it's as if they might have maintained their beauty had they only refrained from
it.
Uh,
you,
you could look at a similar attitude in a prayer for my daughter.
Uh,
another,
uh,
important,
big Yeats poem from a slightly earlier,
uh,
where it says an intellectual hatred is the worst.
So let her think.
His daughter,
that opinions are a cursed,
uh,
women shouldn't have them.
Uh,
this is not an attractive side of the aids,
uh,
at least for,
for,
uh,
people of our moment,
and Sensibility.
Uh,
it,
there's a kind of,
um,
uh,
well masculinism uh,
in,
in the eights and it's part of,
uh,
when I met last time when I,
when I spoke of Yates is anti modernism or his reactionary modernism and it's
here too in this poem.
Uh,
but the attitude here as an eastern 1916 and Yates is other great poems is
complicated,
uh,
for all of Yates is a reactionary moods,
even for his indulgence in the stallion to here.
He's not a nostalgic poet.
Uh,
and,
and this poem I think shows us,
uh,
what I mean by that.
Uh,
look at how the poem changes as it develops a,
as it moves to this second stroke.
Uh,
and Yates turns from the frozen image of the past to address those two sisters
directly,
uh,
saying dear shadows,
now,
you know,
it all,
all the folly of a fight with a common wrong or right,
the innocent and the beautiful have no enemy,
but time
arise and bid me,
strike a match and strike another till time.
Catch.
Should the configuration climb,
run till all the sages?
No,
we built the Great Gazebo.
They convicted us of guilt.
Bid me,
strike a match and blow
the poet and the woman together become we in the poems.
Last sentence.
They,
the they who convicted us of guilt.
Well,
that's hard to identify.
Who is that?
Uh,
I think it's possible to see that they,
as the sort of general forces of modernity,
of everything at odds with the aristocratic culture Yates and these women shared
inhabited,
uh,
we the great gazebo built.
I stumbled and put,
built in the wrong place when I read it.
Uh,
it's a strange line.
I am told,
uh,
that it,
it,
uh,
plays on a,
a slang phrase,
then current to make a gazebo of yourself,
meaning to make a spectacle of yourself and a fool of yourself publicly.
Uh,
the,
uh,
footnote to your Norton here,
suggests
that the Gazebo is a summer house and by extension it's quite an extension,
the nationalist movement.
And then even the whole temporal world.
Those are some real extensions,
aren't they?
Uh,
it's a little hard to know what to do with this,
this gazebo a does it in fact represent,
um,
the,
uh,
nationalist movement,
um,
uh,
that,
um,
uh,
culminated a or one form of,
which culminated in the Easter rebellion.
Uh,
does it represent a Yates his own,
um,
uh,
early cultural nationalism and his,
the,
uh,
work,
representative,
uh,
the wind among the reeds and other early poems?
Well,
it's a little hard to say.
I tend to see that Gazebo or summer house,
uh,
as,
you know,
as a,
as a version of list of Dell itself,
uh,
this,
um,
a home that the poem evokes a and that is representative of a 19th century world
of art,
uh,
of pleasure,
of rarefied and delicate and ideal beauty,
uh,
a world very important to Yates,
as,
uh,
as his thought develops in the course of this poem.
Okay.
Uh,
he,
uh,
turns from nostalgia,
to affirmation,
uh,
and seems to join the sisters,
in the,
uh,
actions,
that they chose through some kind of sympathetic identification,
uh,
Yates who had seemed to stand apart from and against them.
In the first part of the poem,
uh,
the women,
represent,
uh,
48 to kind of self destructive energy.
Uh,
and it's something,
uh,
he too I think is willing to,
share,
uh,
and enter into a,
he speaks of the destruction of the world that they shared at the house that
they had built,
one that he mocks as this great Gazebo,
uh,
as something noble and beautiful,
perhaps,
but also fragile,
uh,
in a spectacle.
And unable to stand up to history.
Time is the enemy in the poem,
uh,
at Yates joins forces with the women at the end.
Uh,
and the,
in doing so joins forces with time,
uh,
and sets a match to it.
Uh,
as if time itself,
we're Tinder Yates
imagines a kind of act of arson in this pub.
Fire is symbolically important.
Throughout his poetry.
In the song of Wandering Angus,
I talked about the,
the kind of flickering passion and the fire in the head,
uh,
that sends Angus out on his quest fire reappears,
with increasing frequency in the late poetry,
uh,
in,
your ris packet.
I gave you the,
a short poem,
two songs from a play.
Uh,
the first stanza of that interesting,
uh,
poem,
a repeats themes from the match I,
and the second coming you can,
you can look at,
uh,
it,
with those palms in mind where Yates imagines a new world coming into being
ushered in through the blood of the old,
uh,
this,
idea,
uh,
leads him to,
um,
uh,
the meditation that's in the,
the second stanza,
uh,
there,
everything that man is steams,
endures a moment or a day,
loves pleasure,
drives his love away.
The painter's brush consumes his dreams.
The heralds cry,
the soldiers tread exhaust his glory in his might.
Whatever flames upon the night man's own resinous heart has fed man's heart in
Yates is resonance.
It's a sticky filth that flames
belonging,
heart accumulates desires that become in time a kind of volatile waste,
uh,
which can't be contained.
Uh,
the heart is combustible,
uh,
like the,
the energy that insists on birth in the magpie or the second coming.
Uh,
and this is our glory.
Yeats says,
uh,
again,
notice how bodily,
how material in physical Yates has images of human energy are.
Let's turn back to uh,
the anthology and,
and look at the poem vacillation on one 31.
Uh,
this is a meditation that comes in several parts.
Um,
as Yates has work develops,
he creates a,
a kind of poem,
uh,
that comes in parts.
Uh,
that is,
uh,
we might think of as a kind of sequence poem,
in which,
um,
uh,
with increasing daring,
Yates explores contending viewpoints,
uh,
seeking,
some kind of synthesis.
Uh,
that's what's going on here.
That's a similar kind of structure in other late [inaudible] poems,
Yates,
uh,
at first thought to call this poem,
what is joy?
Uh,
it takes up his lifelong quest to reconcile extremities,
opposites,
uh,
in his thought,
in his experience,
and to achieve some kind of unity of,
of being,
uh,
what is the goal of,
of wandering Angus,
uh,
between extremities.
Man runs his course,
a brand or flaming breath comes to destroy all those antinomy of day and night.
The body calls it death,
the heart remorse.
But if these be right,
what is joy
here in the first part of the palm?
Yates talks about death and remorse as the end of all debate
the last word.
We're all going to die and we're all going to regret what we did.
But this understanding of the end of things,
uh,
is only the cancellation of all those antinomy.
He's in a kind of failure to reconcile them and it doesn't satisfy Yates.
Uh,
he's asking in
how can we be joyful in the face of death and in the face of certain remorse?
Or how is it that somehow we are,
he wants to explain this.
He wants to,
he wants to find a way to not so much redeem as affirm a time and age,
uh,
and understand them not simply a,
as a cause of despair,
uh,
or as a cause of defeat.
The poem then tries out different answers,
uh,
answers that a alternately explore transcendental and secular,
solutions.
Um,
and at the poem vacillates a as it were between them
in section three below,
uh,
Yates has get all the gold and silver that you can provide provide.
Uh,
but,
uh,
just as in frost,
the strategy isn't going to work.
So therefore,
uh,
we must take up,
he suggests a anesthetic path,
uh,
engaging only as he says in those works that are fit for such men as come proud
and open eyed and laughing to the tomb
in section four.
Then the next on the next page,
uh,
blessing is,
is not,
uh,
on the other hand,
something to work for,
uh,
rather,
it's a potential fire that flashes up momentarily within us.
My 50th year had come and gone when I first read this poem that seemed to really
long way in my future
as perhaps it does do you,
uh,
my 50th year had come and gone.
I sat a solitary man in a crowded London shop,
an open book and Empty Cup on the marble table top while on the shop and street,
I gazed my body of a sudden blazed and 20 minutes more or less.
It seemed so great.
My happiness that I was blessing and could bless.
It's a serendipitous and,
and moving,
uh,
a momentary experience.
Yates describes and notice that it's the body that blazes a soul and body or
soul and heart.
Uh,
these are our antinomy is that the poem is exploring.
A Yates insists that the heart is an organ of the body.
Uh,
they have been located in it.
this,
this is important,
uh,
in,
the sixth section down below.
He speaks of man's blood sodden heart.
So another turn on that image of Man's resinous heart,
uh,
in,
in section seven,
a soul and heart argue,
uh,
the vacillation and debate,
becomes uh,
quickest here.
Uh,
as one point of view gets one line and uh,
the other,
uh,
the a rhyming next line,
well,
they're not in couplets,
but you'll,
you'll hear the rhymes when they come.
Uh,
seek out reality.
Leave things that seem,
that's what the soul instructs us.
The heart responds.
What?
Be a singer born and lack of theme
Isaiah's coal.
What more can man desire struck dumb and the simplicity of fire.
Look on that fire.
Salvation walks within what theme had homer but original sin.
It's,
it's a wonderfully compressed argument in which the soul and the heart make,
compete.
Keep,
excuse me.
Competing claims for Christianity,
uh,
and classical,
and literary wisdom Yates counter poses.
Isaiah is prophetic coal,
uh,
to the blazing body of section four,
a where fire is spontaneous,
imminent,
something that arises from the body.
Uh,
there then follows a,
in that last section,
a kind of comic,
uh,
conclusion where the poet chooses to side with homer,
and implicitly with poetry against,
uh,
the theologian,
von Hugele,
who's a kind of comic figure,
uh,
at the end there,
a vacillation the poem was written,
uh,
following a series of poems called the crazy Jane poems written as a kind of
summary of them and kind of resolution of the debates that go on.
And the,
uh,
you have just one of them in your anthology.
Uh,
but it is a,
one of the,
uh,
greatest,
it is,
uh,
back on one 30,
in the,
uh,
crazy Jane poems.
Uh,
the bishop who is crazy,
Jane's antagonist has as the real,
the part of von Hugele,
the,
uh,
position of the,
um,
church authority,
uh,
and Jane speaks for Yates and for poetry,
for homer to I suppose,
uh,
crazy.
Jane is one of a Yates is masks or roles.
Uh,
she is a mad peasant woman.
um,
she,
uh,
she speaks from the point of view of a cracked or shattered mind.
Uh,
uh,
in the tradition of a Shakespearian fool.
She speaks what gates calls in his general,
uh,
title for this group of poems,
words for music,
perhaps,
uh,
the poems,
connection to music,
uh,
signifies the difference in point of view in these poems from reasons speech.
Uh,
it also seems to relate these poems to folk forms,
uh,
into the wisdom of the folk.
Uh,
Jane speaks in praise of love,
uh,
in praise of satisfaction.
She speaks of the necessary unity of body and soul,
which for her entails a defense of the body,
uh,
defending,
as she does it's knowledge.
It's goodness as a character.
She is sour.
Uh,
she's rank ill tempered,
pungent,
uh,
in all senses.
Uh,
well let's,
let's look at this debate.
I met the Bishop on the road and much said,
he and I,
those breasts are flat and fallen.
Now those veins must soon be dry.
This is the bishop,
uh,
speaking to her of her body,
live in a heavenly mansion,
not in some foul sty,
to which Jane replies,
fair and foul are near of kin in fair needs foul.
I cried.
My friends are gone,
but that's the truth.
Nor grave,
nor bed denied,
learned in bodily lowliness and in the heart's pride.
And she continues.
A woman can be proud and stiff when on love intent,
but love has pitched his mansion in the place of excrement.
For nothing can be sole or whole that has not been rent.
Okay.
The points of view,
again,
are those of the sacred and profane,
the soul and the body.
Uh,
the promise of a heavenly mansion and the reality of a life lived in a foul STI.
The bishop claims one side of the bait.
Jane claims the other,
uh,
but unlike the bishop,
she doesn't want to reject the other.
And this is important.
Speaking for the body.
She speaks for the potential unity of body and soul.
In answer to the promise,
uh,
of the bishops health heavenly mansion in another life,
she claims another sort of house which she calls loves mansion,
which is noble itself,
and which is to be lived here on earth.
Love has pitched his mansion in the place of excrement.
This is an outrageous claim.
Uh,
what does it mean?
look at the claim it's paired with for nothing can be sole or hole that has not
been rent.
Why is it necessary to rent something to make it soul or hole?
Is it unnecessary?
Uh,
only that which is broken.
Jame claims is unified,
uh,
that which appears hole is not
a Yates seems to be insisting through Jane on the necessity of,
of shattering experience to achieve unity of being a witch.
Yates imagines a,
again,
as a union of opposites.
Uh,
again,
think of the rape of later.
Uh,
this is the type of the violent union,
uh,
that Yates imagines,
in which the,
the divine enters the human and the human finds access to the,
to the divine through the beast deal.
And the beast steel is identified in Yates with the heart and with the
irrational,
uh,
and with the uncontrollable,
um,
Yates is a
late poems,
uh,
speak from the point of view of,
of Jane more often than not,
uh,
and yet powerfully we do see him vacillating from different between different
points of view.
We have really no time left to explore them.
But I want to just point you to,
uh,
to important late poems that,
that seem to,
uh,
represent different,
um,
attitudes,
uh,
in late Yates that contrast the kinds of claim that can be made for art.
Uh,
one of them is the,
uh,
moving,
valedictory to his work that is called the circus animals' desertion,
uh,
where,
the poet,
um,
imagines his imagination is having arisen,
uh,
on,
on ladders,
if you will,
out of a what he calls the foul rag bone shop of the heart.
Uh,
and in conclusion,
he imagines,
uh,
giving up,
um,
that,
uh,
terrific,
um,
uh,
drive towards a imagination and idealization,
and uh,
and a return to the rag and bone shop of the heart.
That's a,
uh,
image of art ultimately leading out of art,
to a kind of state of,
uh,
de sublimation.
Contrast this poem,
uh,
to,
Lapis Lazily,
uh,
a,
beautiful and moving late poem on one 35 a that is full of echos,
uh,
from that,
a general introduction to his work that I quoted from,
uh,
earlier,
um,
here.
Yates,
um,
presents us with
an image of art in the form of a Lapis lazily Chinese carving.
Uh,
and he describes the figures on that carving who,
uh,
are,
in some sense,
um,
uh,
representatives of an attitude,
again,
uh,
beyond,
tragedy,
uh,
beyond,
um,
the kinds of,
uh,
social and political apocalypse that a Yates faced in his career.
Uh,
and then he describes also in this poem,
uh,
and Yates concludes,
well with an image of the artwork,
uh,
that I'll,
I'll,
I'll read for you.
Um,
that is a fascinating in itself,
but all is also,
as I suggest,
an image of a Yates is I'm late,
uh,
ideal for what art should be like.
He says,
every discoloration of the stone.
This is on page one 36.
Every accidental crack or dent seems a watercourse or an avalanche or lofty
slope where it still snows,
though doubtless plum or cherry branch sweetens the little halfway house those
Chinaman climb towards.
And I delight to imagine them seated there
in their,
at their altitude looking at the world from within,
uh,
the perspective of art there on the mountain and the sky on all the tragic scene
they stare,
one asks for more informalities accomplished fingers begin to play their eyes.
Mid many wrinkles,
their eyes,
their ancient glittering eyes are gay,
uh,
and their,
is,
uh,
finally again,
an affirmation of this,
uh,
joy,
and,
and Gay Iot,
uh,
here seen as a property of the artwork itself.